und das kann ich verstehen dass man da
richtig richtig sauer wird was ich aber
nicht verstehen kann ist warum man
einfach so maßlos übertreibt und anfängt
sneaker in brand zu setzen dass hier
leute passiert in den letzten tagen in
amerika leute nehmen ihre sneaker teures
liga stellen sie die straße zünden sie
annehmen dass auf und stellen es auf
twitter jetzt stellt sich natürlich
jeder vernünftige mensch die frage warum
machen die das erst mal bevor es losgeht
wenn ihr seht ihr dass der hintergrund
sicher verändert hat ich habe jetzt
einfach die ganze kamerun gedreht das
ding hier oben kommt auch bei irgendwann
auch weg gras wie davon die störung
kommen wir zurück zum thema leute in
amerika zünden ihre schuhe an und
schmeißen ihre schule sogar in den müll
und der rest der welt fragt sich warum
macht ihr das dazu möchte ich euch jetzt
die hintergrundgeschichte erzählen und
zwar kenne ein paar von euch sicher new
balance ich persönlich kenne über das
jetzt schon lange ich habe glaube ich
damals zu meinem 18
geburtstagen pany balance bekommen dass
er meine ersten und ich bin seitdem kein
product placement selbstverständlich
nicht wirklich absolut überzeugt von
revolutionen deswegen bin ich bei diesem
video auch so ein bisschen auf deren
seite ich persönlich finde diese new
balance ramadi 574 einfach geiler als
die nike airport ex die sie damals
hießen oder international ist heute
deshalb meine persönliche meinung können
sich ja jeder eine eigene meinung bilden
aber dieses unternehmen new balance
kommt aus den vereinigten staaten aus
amerika genau genommen aus boston und
der amper mensch also public relations
public relations drpr beauftragter also
quasi deren sprecher für sie in der
öffentlichkeit hat öffentlich gesagt
dass sie donald trumps außenpolitik
unterstützen ja aus politik von dem
typen hier genauer gesagt donald trumps
wunsch ein freihandelsabkommen namens
tpp zu kündigen das haben die quasi
öffentlich gesagt und die reaktionen
darauf waren richtig krass wie league
richtig damit wir hier denkt dass sich
die leute genau deswegen ihre schuhe in
brand gesetzt haben es ist tatsächlich
so wir haben das gelesen und
selbstverständlich sind viele viele
viele in den vereinigten staaten immer
noch richtig sauer weil ihre kandidaten
hillary clinton nicht gewählt wurde und
suchen deswegen jetzt
den grund um ihren frust abzulassen und
wenn dann irgend einen schuhhersteller
aus den vereinigten staaten sagt okay
wir finden es gut dass sonnen trump
dieses freihandelsabkommen kündigen
möchte weil das unsere produktion in den
vereinigten staaten geschützt
dann rasten alle aus und ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen ich kann es ein bisschen
nachvollziehen dass man frustriert ist
wenn die eigene kandidatin ins nicht
wird gerade nachdem das müsste ich mal
vor augen halten die kandidaten 18
monate und noch länger darauf
hingearbeitet haben präsident zu werden
und dann in einer nachmachen
ein gegner alles platt 18 monate umsonst
das ist wirklich krass noch für die
ganzen unterstützer der kandidaten haben
wir genauso 18 monate oder noch länger
gearbeitet nur mit dem ziel dass ihr
kandidat und ihre kandidaten am ende
präsident wird für die eine seite heißt
es am ende einfach [ __ ] you und das kann
ich verstehe dass man da richtig richtig
sauer wird was ich aber nicht verstehen
kann ist warum man einfach so maßlos
übertreibt und anfängt sneaker in brand
zu setzen
beides hat übrigens auch noch dazu auch
noch sagen verkündet dass sie glauben
dass mit trump die dinge in die richtige
richtung gehen eben weil sie denken okay
wir sind ein schuhhersteller der zum
teil noch in den usa produziert und das
ist so selten dass
sportartikelhersteller noch in dem land
produzieren dem sie auch sitzen da ist
die welt gewissermaßen schon da aus da
die sneaker hält und traurig kennen sich
vielleicht ein bisschen näher mit ihm
über land aus und wissen dass die
eigentlich so zwei produktreihe haben
und zwar haben sie schuhe die nicht in
den vereinigten staaten produziert
wurden und schuhe die made in usa sind
also in den vereinigten staaten
produziert wurden und die in den
vereinigten staaten sind deutlich teurer
als die anderen weil eben wenn ihr
verein schon die löhne höher sind und so
weiter und so fort das ist natürlich
alles in den preis schon sein auf jeden
fall haben sie einige produkte die noch
in den vereinigten staaten hergestellt
werden und wie gesagt dass das
sportartikel hersteller eine absolute
ausnahme und damit zum beispiel ich habe
letztens war mein letztes eine lautlose
kaufen ich dachte mich trifft der schlag
ich schaue auf die neigung com webseite
die pizza nehmen einfach 100 euro für
die jogginghose da denkt man echt so
wisst ihr was leute am lotto weit so
oder so ich glaube euch sein gekommen
dass die bands damit eine ausnahme ist
dass sie noch in ihrem heimatland
produzieren und ich persönlich finde
dass ist
ich persönlich finde dass sie nicht jede
industrie sofern es irgendwie geht ihre
jobs ins ausland verschiffen sollte weil
das natürlich immer heißt dass die leute
die es bisher im inland gemacht haben
die bisher in den usa für die bundles
gearbeitet haben oder in deutschland für
trigema ist die dann ihren job verlieren
wenn die produktion an das land geht
würden deutschland produziert und alle
die da bis dahin gearbeitet haben ohne
job und ebay sofort sogar das ziel nicht
nur alle dinge so zu lassen wie sie
jetzt sind sondern sogar noch mehr in
den vereinigten staaten zu produzieren
deswegen freuen sich halt das tram in
die richtung geht die amerikanische
wirtschaft zu schützen das ist so eine
idee die tram hat dass er quasi die
amerikanische wirtschaft gegen die
anderen volkswirtschaften zum beispiel
china und mexiko schützt um im inland
mehr jobs zu schaffen deswegen hat sich
über das gedacht okay der möchte die
amerikanische volkswirtschaft schützen
wir möchten auch die amerikanische
volkswirtschaft geschützt weil wir gerne
mehr in amerika produzieren möchten und
deswegen haben sich wahrscheinlich
gedacht ihr wisst ihr was dann sagen
wir's halt einfach mal öffentlich die
sache ist natürlich so als unternehmen
ein politisches statement zu machen oder
auch als youtube ein politisches thema
zu machen ist eigentlich selbstmord
warum gerade sowie den vereinigten
staaten hat man halt 50 auf der einen
seite 50 demokraten und 50 prozent auf
der anderen seite heißt 50 republikaner
und wenn man sich jetzt für eine seite
entscheiden sollte man sagt okay ich
stehe mit den republikanern dann hassen
die demokraten man sagt okay ich stehe
mit den demokraten
dann hatten die republikaner also mit 50
leute hat man es eigentlich immer
verpackt um ein politisches statement ab
deswegen muss ich sagen war das
vielleicht gar nicht so smart von ihr
bei uns das zu machen aber was zur hölle
ist das für eine reaktion es sind viele
viele viele leute sauer einen
vereinigten staaten wenn ihr euch mal
umschaut den letzten tagen gab es
demonstrationen in vielen vielen städten
wo vor allem jugendliche umgezogen sind
etwas geschrieben haben wie donald trump
oder nochmal präsident also quasi nicht
mein präsident und wenn in so einer
situation natürlich irgendwo unternehmen
kommt und einen anlass gibt das
unternehmen zu hassen weil es sagt hey
wir finden es gar nicht verkehrt was der
hier macht dann geht es natürlich
richtig in die fresse hier übrigens noch
ein paar bilder von anderen typen hier
seine schuhe auf weggeschmissen hat
ich persönlich mag new balance schuhe
einfach mal die mich einfach überzeugt
von der qualität her
es ist so krass man kann so was nicht
mehr sagen auf youtube audi sachs war
für alle die es nicht geschenkt haben
ich habe mit ihm werde es überhaupt
keine beziehung zwischen lienz händen
von ihnen gesehen oder schuhe von dem
bekommt ich mag die rub und deswegen bin
ich natürlich ein bisschen auf deren
seite in dieser sache einerseits bin ich
halt so ein bisschen gegen die leute die
ihre schuhe aus protest darüber anzünden
dass das unternehmen gesagt hat okay der
politik ein da der hat eine idee die uns
gut gefällt jetzt kann man natürlich
sagen weil trump in einer sache
unterstützt unterstützt in allen sache
auch wenn es ziemlich dumm ist das zu
sagen und tun hat natürlich schon viele
viele viele falsche dinge gesagt zum
beispiel diese unfassbar gemein
äußerungen gegenüber frauen
das kann ich einfach nicht mittragen als
mensch der eine kleine schwester hatten
menschen deine mutter hat von euch haben
sich auch noch mutter es geht einfach
nicht aber ich glaube deswegen kann man
trotzdem einzelne dinge die diese person
in der politik machen möchte dennoch gut
finden und die welt hat die gut gefunden
und hier panels hat dafür eine richtige
abfuhr bekommen
ich persönlich finde sogar tief
lächerlich jetzt geht die frage an euch
was haltet ihr von der ganzen aktion
eurem alter zu gerne in die kommentare
und verbrennen oder schuhe lieber nicht